[Musique]
le magicien d'oz mais aussi une
trentaine d'autres films dont celui du
soviétique eisenstein
voilà ce qu'était la sélection du
premier festival de cannes en 1939 le
festival qui n'eut jamais lieu
avant même la guerre ce festival avait
été conçu comme une arme de guerre
idéologique contre la domination des
cinémas fascistes et nazis qui est allé
leur propagande à la mostra de venise un
homme avait voulu se contre-feu leur
laine et jean zay ministre de
l'éducation et de la culture
et voilà qu'après l'entrée au panthéon
de janzé cet aspect de son oeuvre va
être honoré dans sa ville natale du 12
au 17 novembre 2019
orléans va en effet recréé qu'un 1939 le
festival de cannes 39 n'a pu avoir lieu
que sur une sorte d'alliance l'alliance
historique 1 entre le ministre jean zay
ministre de l'éducation nationale et des
beaux-arts et hollywood c'est ça qui a
véritablement rendu possible le festival
face à la mostra de fasciste et face à
l'allemagne nazie donc on veut retrouver
cet esprit là avec un certain nombre de
figures de
américaine et puis européennes
internationales et puis bien sûr le
milieu du cinéma français doit être là à
mobiliser pour ce festival
l'idée c'est vraiment de reprendre
l'esprit de de base du festival à savoir
un événement cinématographique très
conséquent un événement évidemment
politique avec tout un événement de
résistance en trente neuf
on connaît le contexte et puis et puis
aussi l'aspect festif
pendant six jours à orléans vivra ainsi
au rythme de cannes 1939 entre le
théâtre et le cinéma des carmes entre
projections des films sélectionnés en
1939 montée des marches de stars du
cinéma d'aujourd'hui délibération de
quatre jurys et à grand bal en costumes
d'époque